this is where we left off in the
previous video this is the unit circle
with radius 1 and the origin as the
center this length was sin Theta this
length was cos Theta and the length of
this tangent was tan Theta to understand
the relation between the angle Theta and
the functions let's try changing the
angle Theta
let me redraw the figure on a new page
this length is cos this length is s and
this length is tan I'm not writing Theta
next to every function as we doing this
just for our
understanding now let's try increasing
the angle Theta and see what happens to
S cos and
tan let's try increasing Theta first you
can see that Theta is increasing and
with it you can also see sign
increasing and cosine decreases as Theta
increases look what's happening to tan
yes it increases along with Theta what
happens when we decrease Theta s is
decreasing cosine is increasing and tan
is
decreasing the radius remains constant
in each
case now that we have an idea let's look
at four different figures with varying
Theta
measures this is how the figure will
look if Theta is
increased we have just increased the
measure of this angle and kept this one
at
90° now let's analyze the change in the
length the hypotenuse will remain one
unit as it is a unit circle this length
is sin Theta and we can see that it is
increased in length as Theta
increased this length is cos Theta we
can see that this length decreased as
the measure of angle Theta
increased and since this point has moved
upwards the length of tan Theta has also
increased what did we observe as Theta
increased s and tan increased but cos
decreased now let's try increasing the
measure of theta even more the this is
how it will look the hypotenuse Still
Remains one as it is a unit
circle sign has increased even more and
cost has decreased again and the length
of the tangent has increased as this
point has moved further up so again as
Theta increased s and tan increased
while cos
decreased what if Theta becomes
90° yes the triangle won't exist it will
look something like this this length
will be sin Theta if Theta is 90° then
sin Theta will equal 1 unit as it
becomes the radius of the
circle cos Theta becomes zero and tan
cannot be defined in this
figure so the unit circle tells us that
as Theta increases s and tan increase
while C
reduces what we just learned is valid
for the first quadrant of the Cartesian
plane but you can apply the same concept
to all other
quadrants there is another important
result that the unit circle gives us
observe all the triangles they are all
right
triangles so according to the Pythagoras
Theorem the hypotenuse squar will equal
the sum of the squares of the other two
sides the hypotenuse squared in every
case is 1 2 which is 1 and the other two
sides in every triangle are sin Theta
and cos
Theta hence we can say that sin Theta 2
+ cos Theta s will equal 1 2 which is
1 it is written as Sin s Theta + cos s
Theta = 1 this is considered one of the
most important trigonometric identities
which was derived easily using a unit
circle doesn't matter what the measure
of theta is sin s theta plus cos squ
Theta will always equal
1 many people have a lingering doubt in
their mind when they study this topic
what if the radius was two will this
still work the answer is yes it will
let's assume the radius was two so OB
would be two in this case sin Theta
would be AB by
2 and ab would be 2 sin Theta similarly
O A would be 2 cos Theta using the
Pythagoras Theorem we can say that 2 sin
Theta the whole 2 + 2 cos Theta the
whole s will equal 2^
2 dividing the entire equation by 4 we
will get sin 2 Theta + cos s Theta = 1
it doesn't matter what the radius is
this will always be
[Music]
true